[Music]
[Applause]
demonstrators march on the streets of
the capital carrying the photos of the
dead and Banners portraying president
dinaboloarte as a murderer
thousands of people in Lima and Southern
Peru blame her for the killings most of
the victims were young poor indigenous
gunned down in confrontations with the
Army and police who used live ammunition
to disperse crowds of anti-government
protesters
I'm upset angry traumatized and shocked
by What's Happening Here I believe that
people are going to force Dina balate
and Congress out
the worst violence in Peru in two
decades has also prompted the governors
of three Southern regions where most of
the protesters were killed to urge the
President to resign they say it's the
only way to start resolving the
spiraling unrest
Ortiz lost a brother in a massacre when
Alberto fujimori was in power she says
the current government must go
I think that a government that has
presided over so many deaths is
unsustainable we are all in favor of
democracy but it does not make sense if
they don't respect the lives of the
people
prime minister Alberto tarola says in
control and stepping down is out of the
question
I want to say it very clearly the
president is not going to resign that
will not happen because leaving the
presidency would be to open a very
dangerous door to Anarchy and this
government and that will not happen
in puno in the South families of the 17
people killed by security forces in
julyaka earlier this week held a funeral
procession accompanied by thousands of
mourners
Dina you killed my husband why I hate
you Dina
[Music]
president boluarte's Andean she grew up
in a purimak one of the country's
poorest regions angry peruvians accused
her of turning a deaf ear to their
complaints
demonstrators because they say their
voices are not being heard
they're threatening to march to Lima in
the coming days to join rallies in the
capital and say they will keep up their
protests until bonuarte is out of office
Mariana sanchezida Lima